especially since the all-star break he's  below 25  since the rank  towns flushes  rises quickly for the for the dunk  [Music]  [Applause]  he's got a second dunk already numbers  for san antonio  [Applause]  and the wolves catch a break  towns  gets paid off on the other end  [Applause]  towns  attacks and finishes so carl doesn't  lose his aggressiveness there  [Music]  [Applause]  46 for cat  [Applause]  towns  steps back drills to triple  make it 54 in the game  nine three-point attacks for carl  anthony towns in this game he's been  averaging three a game in the month of  march towns  making 32 in the quarter and he's tied  the franchise record 56  in the game  [Applause]  [Applause]  100 chance  what a night yeah the skill of carl  anthony towns is off the charts  and in incredible for the nba to have  three bigs  with the talent level of towns